قرعت طبول الحرب
بانتظار إشعال الفتيل،
فشلت الوساطات والمفاوضات،
من سيغلب من؟
ومن سيقف مع من؟
وإلى أي مدى ستتأثر أوروبا
المتعطشة للطاقة بالغزو الروسي المحتمل لأوكرانيا؟
أسئلة أصبحت واضحة للعيان،
فهل تتحول مصانع الغذاء إلى مصانع للسلاح؟
وهل ينزح الغرب وأوروبا تحديدا
إلى الدول العربية كملاذ آمن؟
أم هل تصبح الدول العربية
ساحة لهذه المعركة؟
لكن بعد كل تلك التصريحات والتهديدات
من سيفي بوعده ويلتزم بكلامه؟..
وماذا عن هذا المجنون أي صف سيختار؟
لم يعد السؤال ماذا لو قامت الحرب
بين روسيا وأوكرانيا،
بل إن الحرب على وشك الاندلاع،
فهل تنتصر بها بلد وتسحق أخرى
ليذهبها الجوع الفقر؟
بين خيارات عسكرية واقتصادية وسياسية،
بدأت رائحة الحرب العالمية الثالثة
تفوح في الأرجاء. فما هي السيناريوهات  المحتملة ؟
وما هي الخطط المتوقعة لهذه الحرب؟
يبدو أن أوكرانيا ستكون في خبر كان
فيما لو استخدمت روسيا أسلحتها الفتاكة!!
فلو قررت روسيا الهجوم الجوي،
فقد تسبب أضرارا بالغة في الأراضي الأوكرانية،
لكن لو استطاعت أوكرانيا استخدام مضادات
الطيران الأمريكية هناك سيتغير المشهد،
فمنظومة أم آي أم-104 باتريوت
قد تفي بالغرض لتخفيف وطأة الضربات الجوية الروسية،
وتكبد روسيا خسائر متعددة
روسيا أيضا قد تستخدم سلاحا فتاكا مرعبا
وهو سلاح الشمس الحارقة أو قاذفات اللهب الثقيلة،
لكن هذا السلاح قد يجعل روسيا
أمام إجماع دولي ضدها لأن هذا السلاح
يسبب إبادات جماعية،،،
أما في البحر فتستطيع روسيا استخدام
غواصة وسيدوون النووية
لدك أي أسطول بحري قادم من أمريكا
وحلف الناتو لدعم أوكرانيا،،
بينما تستطيع أوكرانيا استخدام سلاح الجو الأمريكي
في حال دعمتها أمريكا به،
وبالتالي ستكون هناك غارات جوية
باستخدام إف ٣٥
إحدى أقوى الطائرات المقاتلة في العالم،،
لكن روسيا لديها منظومة الدفاع الجوي
إس٤٠٠، لتبقى كل هذه الأسلحة
مجرد احتمالات وتوقعات،،،
أما على أرض الواقع، فهي المرة الأولى
التي تعلن أوكرانيا أنها مستعدة لأي حرب مع روسيا،
في ظل هذه الأجواء المشحونة بالتوتر
تم الكشف عن أن جميع الأجهزة
وقطاعات الجيش يجري تعبئتها لحماية البلاد،
من حرب دموية هي الأقسى في تاريخ أوكرانيا،،
وبينما تعلن كييف أنها لم تقم بعد باستقدام
قوات أجنبية، فإن قواتها تتلقى تدريبات مكثفة
على أيدي خبراء أمريكان وإنجليز
ومن دول أوروبية أخرى،،
على الأرض فإن مناوشات تدور بين أوكرانيا
والانفصاليين المدعومين من روسيا،
وسط خروقات لوقف إطلاق النار يسقط فيها
العديد من القتلى من الجانبين،
من جانبها هددت ألمانيا المسؤولين في روسيا
أن أي هجوم على الأراضي الأوكرانية،
فإنها ستجعلهم يتحملون عواقب شخصية.
وتدعو ألمانيا دول حلف شمال الأطلسي
أن تضع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والمحيطين به نصب أعينهم،،
في خطوة أخرى لوحت أوكرانيا بورقة الغاز،
داعية الدول الأوروبية لمقاطعة الغاز الروسي،
لصد ما أسمته بالعدوان الروسي على أراضيها،
والضغط أكثر على الروس برفع خسائرهم الاقتصادية
قبل حتى أن تبدأ الحرب،،،
على الجانب الآخر:
...
روسيا نشرت أكثر من 100 ألف جندي
على الحدود مع أوكرانيا وبهذه الطريقة
هي تضع الغرب أمام عدة خيارات منها:
(تطويق الجيش الأوكراني)
يشير الخبراء إلى أن معظم القوات العسكرية الأوكرانية
متمركزة على طول خط التماس
في منطقة دونباس، حيث تواجه الجيش الشعبي
التابع لدونباس والمدعوم من الروس.
وإذا حركت روسيا بسرعة وحدات مدرعة إلى منطقة
غرب خط التماس، فقد تنجح في عزل
معظم القوات البرية الأوكرانية
دون الحاجة إلى احتلال المدن الكبرى،
وبهجوم سريع سيتمكن الجيش الروسي
من القضاء على الجيش الأوكراني وأسلحته ومعداته.
(حصار الموانئ الأوكرانية)
ظهور سينارو جديد لروسيا
وهو إغلاق مدينتي بيرديانسك وماريوبول البحريتين
في الجنوب الشرقي، وبالتالي ستقوم روسيا
بإغلاق قناة شحن مهمة.
أما في البحر الأسود،
فستكون السفن الحربية الروسية
قادرة على إغلاق مواني أوديسا
ونيكولاييف وخيرسون
والتي تعد طرقا حيوية للأسواق العالمية،
ما سيشكل ضغطا كبيرا على الاقتصاد الأوكراني
الذي يعاني أساسا من مشاكل وأزمات كبيرة،
وبالتالي ستتمكن روسيا من محاصرة الموانئ
الأوكرانية كافة وتفرض قوتها العسكرية
على الشواطئ دون أي مقاومة.
...
(توسيع منطقة دونباس والسيطرة عليها)
قد تدخل القوات الروسية المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
"الانفصاليون" في جمهوريتي لوغانسك ودونيتسك
المعلنتين من جانب واحد، "
بهدف استعراض للقوة ليس أكثر"
ما سيسمح لروسيا بإبقاء التوترات عالية
مع كييف دون الحاجة إلى إطلاق رصاصة،
بحسب بعض الخبراء.
(الاستيلاء على النصف الشرقي من أوكرانيا)
في أسوأ السيناريوهات، حسب التقارير،
قد تطلق روسيا حملة جوية وبرية
عبر أوكرانيا للاستيلاء على منطقة دونباس بأكملها
في الضفة الشرقية لنهر دنيبر.
وحسب الخبراء الأمريكيين، فإن روسيا "
قد تستولي على جزء كبير من شرق أوكرانيا
وتطالب بترتيب سياسي جديد من كييف
أو قد تضم المنطقة ببساطة".
...
روسيا  أكدت مرارا وتكرارا
أنها لا تنوي شن أي تحرك عسكري ضد أوكرانيا،
مؤكدة  أن كل الادعاءات التي تتحدث عن ذلك
لا أساس لها من الصحة،
وحملت الناتو المسؤولية عن التوتر في المنطقة،
خاصة في ظل أنشطة الحلف للتوسع شرقا
نحو حدود روسيا.
بينما حذرت الخارجية الروسية في وقت
سابق من أن "التصرفات غير المسؤولة" للغرب
في إطار ملف أوكرانيا
تثير مخاطر عسكرية كبيرة،
قد تصل إلى نشوب نزاع واسع النطاق في أوروبا.
في أوكرانيا هناك جيش متأهب
وهناك أمريكا وتحالف الناتو في الانتظار،
أما في الطرف المقابل
فهناك روسيا، فإلى أين المصير؟